-Our first guest tonight
is an Academy
and Golden Globe Award-winning
actor you know from the hit
TV series "Fargo"
and films such as "Sling Blade,"
"Bad Santa,"
and "Friday Night Lights."
He stars in the fourth and final
season of "Goliath,"
which is now streaming
on Amazon Prime Video.
Let's take a look.
-Let's put this to bed
for $10 million.
-Zax and Tillinger
and Russell Drug
flooded this country
with billions of pills.
You get them hooked,
and you sell them more.
People die.
Who gives a [bleep]?
You can always hook a new
customer with a bad back.
You know,
George Zax had the balls
to give out free 30-day
prescriptions to new patients.
-Zax Pharma has settled.
-Yeah, not on my watch.
Your clients
have been reckless.
They killed over 200,000 people
for profit.
That's a targeted business plan.
Now, I may be new here.
Maybe I'm just
getting up to speed.
But I'm in the mood
to stick my fist up your ass
and pull out billions.
You get it?
-Please welcome back to the show
Billy Bob Thornton.
How are you, friend?
-Hey, what's up, Seth?
-That's a hell of a clip
they sent along.
Thank you very much for that.
-Yeah.
Oh, that's just one
of many, many gems.
-So I obviously this has been
a difficult couple of years
for a lot of people,
but I did not know that you had
this added negative element
that you are a germaphobe,
which must have made it
especially hard.
-Yeah, yeah.
I've always been that way.
I've got, you know,
a few phobias.
And I really didn't change
when the pandemic came along.
I was already doing all
that stuff anyway, you know?
It's like, you know,
wash your hands constantly.
I already do. So, yeah.
Worked out nice.
-You're one of those people
who already had gloves
at your house?
-Oh, absolutely.
Hazmat suits. Everything.
-So, one thing that you were
able to do at home,
which must have made it
a little bit nicer --
You're also a musician.
You have a band.
And is it true that you recorded
four albums
since this thing started?
-Three, yeah.
We did three albums,
which was pretty nice
because when we went
to the recording studio,
we just, you know -- it was
kind of a bubble there also.
And, yeah, so we have three
new Boxmasters albums,
including a Christmas album
that we're putting out
in November,
which is not your typical
Christmas album.
It's not "Let it snow,
let it snow", you know?
It's a little darker,
a little sadder,
you know, than most
Christmas albums might be.
-Well, I think we'd expect
nothing less from Bad Santa,
you know?
-Exactly, yeah.
-Now, is that Captain Beefheart
behind you?
-That is absolutely
Captain Beefheart, yes.
-Do you have a lot
of your favorite photos
of your favorite artists
on the wall at your home,
or is he a special exception?
-Well, no, I'm actually
in the recording studio
right now, in the lounge
of the recording studio
that we have out here
in California.
And I was friends
with a famous photographer
named Jim Marshall.
And Jim photographed, you know,
everybody back in the day,
and he was quite a character.
And I have a collection
of Jim's photos here.
And we had a deal, Jim and I.
He would sell me one,
which weren't cheap, and --
and he would give me one.
So that was really cool.
And he knew that I was a big fan
of Frank Zappa
and Beefheart and all them.
And so he would always give me
their photos
if I would buy a Janis Joplin
or whatever.
-I read an article about
one of my favorite artists,
Warren Zevon,
that talked about a time
that he was --
just stopped by your studio
and was just hanging out
and actually recorded
some stuff there.
Was he someone that you were
lucky enough to know long-term,
or was that just
a one-time thing?
-No, I knew Warren
since the late '80s.
When I was -- I was living
in an apartment building
on Kings Road in L.A.
in West Hollywood.
And Warren was my neighbor.
He lived in the building, too.
And -- You know how
in apartment buildings
you have this bank of mailboxes?
You go and check your mail
before you go up
to your apartment.
And the first time I met Warren,
we didn't meet through
the entertainment business.
We met at the mailbox.
And I have severe OCD,
and so did Warren.
And he was standing next to me
checking his mail,
and I opened my mailbox
and pulled the mail out,
put it back in, closed it,
opened it again.
I did that three times,
and he was watching.
And he goes,
"You have it, too, huh?"
And I go, "Yeah, I do."
So then we got to be friends.
And it became a competition
on who had the worst OCD.
[ Laughter ]
And, by the way,
as bad as mine is, he won.
And so...
But he ended up,
on his last album,
you know,
before he passed away.
He used to come
to the house a lot,
and we hung out quite a bit.
And he recorded about three
of the songs for his last album
in my old studio
that I had bought from Slash.
And he actually did
"Knockin' on Heaven's Door"
in my studio,
which was pretty chilling,
because, you know,
Warren knew he was dying.
And when he recorded that
in the studio,
I'll never forget
just sitting there listening.
I did background vocals
with a couple of other guys
on that song with him.
And -- It was pretty chilling.
-Yeah, I mean, I remember,
you know,
that when that album came out
and listening to him
sing that song,
and, obviously, you were aware
that he knew
what his diagnosis was.
So I can only imagine,
as sort of haunting
as it was to listen to it
off the album,
I can't imagine what it was like
to record it with him.
What a piece of history that is.
-No, it was amazing.
And I remember that night,
Warren had a silver ring
that he wore.
It was just kind of
a square silver ring.
Didn't have any markings on it
or anything.
And he said, "I've worn
this ring for a long time."
And he said,
"I want you to have it."
And Warren had
a very dark sense of humor.
And he handed it to me,
and I held it there,
and he looked at me and he said,
"You're not gonna wear it,
are you?"
I said, "No, of course not."
And he goes,
"I knew you wouldn't."